who was the celestial teammate from the
movie eternals well the mcu did tweak a
little bit on what he was irishm the
judge told the eternals that he was a
new celestial being born inside the
earth and that he needed to feed off of
the sentience and intelligence of humans
to be ready to emerge into the wider
universe
anyway let us tell you his real
backstory and compare it with the one
given to us in the recently released
movie oh yeah spoilers ahead now let's
get down with this sickness
in the mcu a celestial seat was sent to
the planet earth millions of years ago
as directed by the celestial irishman
the seed fell like a media into the
earth burrowing deep into the core to
rest it would take a lot of energy from
sentient life forms for it to grow as
with all celestial birds apparently
the rising celestial known as steamwood
would start to grow off of the energy of
the primitive human race that inhabited
its host planet but the energy was
insufficient to grow the celestial due
to the species primitive status
the planet was also infested with
deviance which made the conditions worse
arishim then dispatched 10 eternals to
earth in order to exterminate added
deviance and assure humanity's evolution
and therefore the birth of tirmud
but is this really true or just a piece
of information given by arashim to the
eternals in order to hide the true form
and the true nature of a celestial that
even galactus feared yes it was this was
one of the few beings in the marvel
universe that brought fear into galactus
eyes the same devourer of worlds the one
and only survivor of a previous universe
imagine the power and the status dearmod
really had in order to make the world
either feel fear
but this wasn't the case as was shown in
the mcu as it could have repercussions
in the entire storytelling of the
cinematic universe
this was a being that even the watcher
the same one from the what if series
couldn't see him when he awoke
in the comics deviants were a dominant
force on earth and tamed the dreaming
celestial was ready to call the horde
another collective of beings meant to
harvest planets however irishim canceled
that order and had many of the deviants
killed the dreaming celestial deemed
irish him to be malfunctioning and tried
to assume command by attacking him the
dreaming celestial then found himself
attacked by all the other celestials
cause it took their combined might to
subdue him and he was imprisoned
underneath the mountains the other
celestials ripped his spirit from his
body and placed it inside of device
known as the vial they then sealed the
dreaming celestial's body in a wall
under the diablo mountains in california
and for millennia the celestial slept
the dreaming celestial was one of the
most powerful celestials one classified
as tiemoue the communicator with the
function of alerting the fulcrum of
being who is essentially the creator god
of the marvel universe he was tasked to
alert him of the findings of the
celestials during planetary examinations
and send a signal to the heart and to
collect the planet's aggregate life
force to be transmitted to the fulcrum
once completed in the end when he awoke
from his slumber he decided to spare the
earth against the will of the fulcrum
and so with this he became the only
celestial to break free of his
programmed task and purpose and then
join the fulcrum as a companion to
oversee and design the universe
so this brings us back to the mcu and
whether the celestial seed planted by
irishim onto the planet earth was in
fact teamwork all along being sealed off
inside the planet for his rebellion
against the prime celestial and also we
saw the birth of a celestial in the
movie meaning the immediate destruction
of the planet but tiamat's awakening was
slow and rather peaceful aside from the
obvious tsunamis and since the cinematic
universe always changed a bit from the
comics but also attained the same basic
storyline it isn't far-fetched to think
that tiamut was just asleep all along
for 7000 years and that it was his time
to wake up and thus by killing him or
turning him into stone details were in
fact doing irishm the judge a favor and
that is why there was no interference
from his end
so tell us what you think of the
dreaming celestial and whether his
depiction in the movie screens did him
justice when compared with the comics
cause honestly
though his emergence was awesome the
story was [ __ ]
anyway we have come to the end of the
video and do tell us what your thoughts
are in the comments section so like for
support subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family and click that bell icon
for regular updates on new master
content right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam